i've done these demos in front of live
audiences i remember one time i did one
demo in front of alumni i forget what it
was but it was good failure
and this one little kid
he was only about four years old he
raised his hand he said
you win some and you lose some
today on chalk radio we're talking about
the course
5.310 laboratory chemistry
this is a course that not only teaches
students about hands-on science but also
life
because working in a lab is a lot like
baking
you can follow the recipe but your cake
might still collapse
i'm your host sarah hansen
in this episode we're joined by two mit
educators who have helped shape this
standout course
they'll tell us more about what it looks
like to support students with various
academic interests as they develop lab
skills overcome setbacks and apply their
studies to real world problems like
water quality
i'm john dolan currently director of the
undergraduate chemistry teaching labs at
mit
i'm sarah hewitt and i am a technical
instructor in the chemistry department
at mit
for many of their students
5-3-10 is the first time they step foot
in a college-level chemistry lab
and that can be a memorable experience
the first thing you would see
are lines of student coat lockers
and that's the first thing the students
encounter when they when they enter the
lab
it's here where they would put their
bags and they stored their lab coats and
their goggles
and you would soon see walking out into
the lab that it's divided into twelve
bays
each bay has
six to seven fume hoods and desk space
for
up to 14 students
and lots and lots of windows
something i may have read a bit too much
into
you can correct me i always thought it
was because in case there's an explosion
they want like all the windows to blow
out instead of like the walls of the
building
maybe i maybe i'm not explosion
john went on to explain that yes you
would see windows but explosions
not so much
anyway let's get back to what you
actually would see in this lab
we have some really neat instruments
that the students can operate hands-on
exactly what the students would
experience in industry
carry 60 uv vis spectrometers
state-of-the-art density meters and
refractometers
and one of the really exciting
instruments is an inductively coupled
plasma mass spectrometer
there are only two of these at mit
and this instrument is used exclusively
in 5310
and the students actually use that
to test their river samples to determine
the concentration of 29 different
elements
down to the part per trillion level
so it's pretty exciting
the river sample testing is part of what
makes 5310 unique
students get to take their lab work
right into boston's own charles river
yes the most exciting experiment i think
for most of the students is the ellen
swallow richard's lab
so the students actually go down to the
river and take water samples and then
they get to analyze those samples back
up in the lab for dissolved oxygen
phosphate concentration and a bunch of
other elements so they get to learn a
little bit about environmental chemistry
and analytical chemistry and different
techniques that we use for those types
of analyses and the students really like
that because it's very applicable to the
charles river and
to the boston environment and they can
see it and say oh wow i'm actually doing
something that's kind of useful and
something that they always hear about
how dirty the charles river used to be
and they're actually kind of surprised
when they do the lab now about how good
the water quality is
you may have caught that sarah and john
refer to this as the ellen swallow
richards lab
it's a namesake with significant meaning
when i wrote this lab in 2010 i actually
called it the charles river lab
the reason i wrote the lab was to
introduce an environmental component
into the 5310 laboratory chemistry
course
and sometime after i had wrote the lab i
actually was walking through the halls
at mit
and somehow i ended up in the lobby of
building two
and i looked up and i saw this plaque in
this photo of this
woman on the wall
and i started reading it and it said
this was the first female student ever
admitted to mit
who graduated in 1873.
it was ellen swallow richards who was an
industrial safety engineer and
environmental chemist and it was really
her work i think in 1887
which led to the first state water
quality standards in the nation
and that was very significant and that
kind of moved me to rename the charles
river lab the ellen swallow richards lab
the groundwork laid by ellen swallow
richards has never been more important
in a way that feels particularly
relevant for my own community
and likely for some of yours
one of the local issues that has come up
in the cambridge area and around the
country is the issue of pfas which are
per and polyfluoroalkyl substances
which are man-made chemicals that have
been around for less than 100 years so
they're relatively new but they
encompass things like teflon and other
chemicals like that that are involved in
non-stick coatings for food and also in
fire suppression technology because
they're really flame resistant and stain
resistant and stick resistant
so now they're being detected in water
supplies and in the food chain and
scientists are pretty worried about
their impact on human health and they're
still not entirely sure what all of the
impacts are but there's been a lot of
research recently into
detecting these in the environment and
trying to figure out what their impact
is
on health
as you might imagine most students
aren't ready to go out into the field on
day one of 5 30 10.
the first step is learning how to be
safe in the lab
and learning how to interact with
chemicals and instruments in the lab can
be daunting
they're coming in and they're afraid
some of them have never ever been in a
wet lab before
you've got to make them feel really
comfortable
even though they might be a fourth year
student at mit
graduating
the really fun thing about 5310 is that
there isn't really a typical student we
get students from all types of majors
that take the course so it's a
requirement for medical school and it's
a requirement for the chemical
engineering major so we get
a bunch of chemical engineers and some
med school or pre-med students but
they all come from majors all across the
institute which is really fun so even
though a lot of them are have not taken
a chemistry lab maybe since high school
or ever
they have a lot of science knowledge and
knowledge of other things that is always
kind of interesting sometimes after the
lectures they'll come up and say oh this
reminds me of something from my other
class and that's how i learn a lot too
just from talking to them and hearing
about their experiences
they actually end up helping each other
so some of them who say oh i've worked
in a biology lab i might have more
experience with pipetting can help
students who maybe have not taken a lab
class in many years
for beginner and experienced chemistry
students alike 5310s labs are a
challenge
that means john and sarah have thought
carefully about what kinds of support
their students might need
many many schools
use a lab manual
and they use experiments that are very
clearly
published out and the students go
through
maybe 12 experiments in a semester
and they're very systematic in terms of
the the types of experiments that are
there they're traditional experiments
but with mit
some of the experiments are multi-day
multifaceted experiments
that are actually put together
and can be quite challenging
you know a typical experiment could be
50 to 60 pages long
in terms of helping them deal with
frustration i believe in divide and
conquer for example
one of the things that's very difficult
and challenging and stressful might be
writing up the lab report
that might take them 10 to 15 hours of
time
so we teach them how to break this up
to deal with small frustrations
systematically
do small parts of it early on and don't
wait till the end to do the whole thing
it's kind of like them working on tiny
ant hills instead of a big mountain
and so by forming these good habits
they'll soon be able to deal with
mountain-sized frustration
i'm a product of mit and it works for me
in addition to building the perseverance
chemistry requires both students and
instructors are also actively
cultivating curiosity and making
mistakes in the process
students love diapers and as soon as you
pull a diaper out that totally gets them
relaxed and
loosens them up
the polymer demo is all about sodium
polyacrylate and that's the diaper
polymer that's the chemical in the
diapers that absorbs the water at 800
times its weight
you know when i do this demo i usually
call on a volunteer and unbeknownst to
the volunteer
i've already put some powder in the cup
and i start pouring water in a cup
and i asked the volunteer to tell me
when to stop when they tell me to stop i
put a plastic cover on the cup
and turn it over
and then i put it on their head
usually i ask them to hold it so they
can assume any responsibility for
for that water in the cup coming out
but usually nothing comes out
because the polymer has absorbed all the
water right
you get this beautiful globular polymer
inside this cup and you knock it out
into a dish and you can see it
but i remember when i did this demo
at one of the
mit parents visiting weekends
and there were about 70 to 80 people in
the audience
and i asked for a volunteer to come down
so he came down
but he didn't tell me soon enough to
stop pouring the water in the cup so i
just kept going till he said stop right
so i covered the cup up
very carefully turned it over on this
hard plastic and i put it on his head
and
the polymer and all the water when i
pulled the card out it all came out and
he messed up his hairdo
it was a gooey gooey mess and
the audience just loved it i mean we had
to clean him up with paper towels
you know in front of everybody so
there's often unexpected fun in these
live demos
yes i think that's one of the fun parts
about the lab is that not everything
works even if it doesn't work always for
demos but even in the lab you can have
two students follow the exact same
procedure and sometimes it just doesn't
come out or they'll make one little
error that they didn't even notice and
then it won't work and so
that is definitely something that we
deal with a lot in the lab dealing with
that frustration and having the students
say well
trying to figure out what went wrong and
how to fix it for next time but that is
a big part of what happens in the lab
and a big lesson i think that comes out
that's very unrelated to chemistry but
very important for life
[Music]
another important aspect of this course
is its emphasis on science communication
a few years ago
we looked at the course and we saw the
necessity of writing and for students to
be able to communicate their their work
to a general audience of non-scientists
by working with writing rhetoric and
professional communication instructors
students learn how to write and present
the paper to a general audience
we came up with a bunch of different
topics that are related to water quality
and the charles river and all of the
data that we gather for that lab
students can choose which genre they
would like to write so some examples
that we have are there's a hospital memo
about mercury levels and fish that we
measure with our mercury analyzer so
they can use the data to make arguments
about that there are policy memos for
the government talking about why it's
important to limit phosphate
concentration and pollution in the water
it challenges them to think about how to
communicate science in these different
ways and the writing instructors have
been amazing in helping them learn how
to write in these different styles
i never learned
to write science from a writing
perspective it was always just in my
science classes from other scientists
and so i would recommend it to any other
instructor to bring in writing help if
you have it because it carries over to
their lab reports too because they have
all these skills of how to read their
own work and how to assess it for
clarity and all those things
one thing about mit faculty that we love
is their commitment to sharing their
teaching materials with everyone
i was curious what motivated sarah and
john to do this sharing the course
materials is a
really helpful resource to other
instructors because i know i've
benefited from talking to people that i
went to graduate school with about what
they're doing and going to conferences
and learning from other people and so
the more that we can share and make
available
these materials the more it can help
other instructors and also to introduce
more people to chemistry if they have
their one experience of a chemistry
course then
maybe they can go online and see hey
maybe this other place is taught in a
different way that's way more
interesting or i think that that's
something that i might like to do so i
think it benefits everybody to be more
open with what's going on
opencourseware has such a good
reputation in terms of people all over
the world that actually turn to open
courseware to open a course and actually
learn the material from that course i've
had students
freshman advisees who have come in
who've learned everything that they know
from
opencourseware it's quite dramatic when
you have a student come in and they
literally can test out of every subject
but they've learned all of those
subjects from watching open courseware
before we go i also asked sarah and john
what they would like to ask you our
listeners about teaching laboratory
chemistry
yeah i think i'd be
curious to know what demos some of the
other educators do in their laboratory
chemistry courses and also what types of
non-traditional labs they're running
i think my favorite question to ask
other lab instructors is what is the
purpose of teaching lab
so a lot of people have different
answers to that which is always kind of
interesting and then also another
question that i've been thinking about
is how to prepare students for what
they're going to be doing next whether
it's going into industry or academia or
pre-med what can we do in the lab to
help them with that whether it's
chemistry related or not
if you have insights to share please get
in touch with me at the link in our show
notes
i'll be sure to pass your ideas along to
john sarah and other listeners
if you're interested in learning more
about laboratory chemistry or remixing
sarah and john's open educational
resources in your own teaching head on
over to our mit open courseware website
thank you so much for listening until
next time signing off from near the
charles river i'm your host sarah hansen
from mit open courseware
truck radio's producers include myself
red pachy and dave lashansky
scriptwriting assistance from aubry
callaway
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
the 5310 ocw core site was built by
alicia frankie we're funded by mit open
learning and supporters like you
you